starts fast I think that's the main
thing
um again we've seen it a few times
throughout this tournament and if you
can keep your lead on the clock you will
get chances no matter what and it's a
repeat it's the exact same opening and
Magnus raises his eyebrows and he's like
how dare you do that to me twice uh and
uh okay this time he's come ready he
plays the move A6 that's not what we saw
earlier and a double fianchetto pushing
both the G and B pawns forward whites
Bishops are gonna line up on the longest
possible diagonals interesting play he's
playing a slower approach either you
attacking the Armageddon or you keep the
tension and try to win on the clock
confuses maybe mixing matching doing
both remember there is no increment in
this game Magnus Carlsen with a win or a
draw will be the winner of the Julius
bear generation cup if aloe reservous
wins this game he will take it to a
grand final reset with best out of two
games yeah and we want to see more chess
of course but uh far Asia he still needs
to win this game first and at least in
terms of opening it's much healthier for
Magnus no King problems the last thing
you want in Armageddon chess is to be
facing an attack like he was in the last
game with the King stranded in the
center both sides have developed very
naturally this position is going to
revolve around the center playing with
that weak born
I think so I think I think he plays
these positions quite a lot and this is
where having the draw in hand is is very
handy because isolated Pawn positions
they often give what the person playing
against them white in this case the
advantage the black pawn in the middle
if you're not sure what isolate Pawn is
is weak it can't be defended by another
uh Pawn there using the time on the
clock and there we see him Retreat the
night I didn't quite like this move
because it was self-pinning it's very
passive and it felt like it was a little
bit loose
and I'm just if I were Magnus I would be
just thinking about either stepping the
queen forward or this one which one I
preferred just to introduce the Rook to
the open lines
yeah really awkward move I guess this is
the first sign we've seen from furusia
that he's desperate in this must win
situation for the full point and this
like not uh This Kind of Night Retreat
that he's gone for
it's Last Resort type of thing it's
basically if you see no other attractive
options maybe you thought others would
lead to simplifications trades and a
draw so he's put his Knight on a bad
Square now he's blocked in White's light
squared Bishop he's breaking the rules
here you can't do that
and also take a look at the white king
it's on an open diagonal
I just feel like and and then the bishop
now comes to a loose Square
loose pieces drop off this feels really
vulnerable and really kind of edgy from
fruition not in a good way especially
when there's no real calculation to be
done it's just about feeling peace
placement you don't get extra time this
is such a key thing so so he has gone
for your movie van and um the the
problem is that this this time ticking
down you can get flagged a lot and Ali
raises very quick when he wants to be
but good move here I like this move you
if you go to B2 there's also Bishop A3
so maybe this is one of the only squares
which is reasonably safe here but the
white pieces are lacking Harmony here uh
if you could put the pawn on F3 back on
F2 whether light Square Bishop is going
then great but Magnus just improving uh
each move looking good for Magnus so far
but not on the clock
yeah and uh Ali Reza will have to go and
full-on calculation mode as he had to
anticipate black porn stepping forward
and Magnus responding quickly with a
bishop coming to a through A3 the bishop
is threatening to come to B2
you can't grab this isolated Queen's
Pawn black porn in the center of the
board with the white knight because uh
the other white knight would be hanging
there and look at this Magnus is just
saying I'm going to keep coming forward
to keep pouring forward evaluation Bar
says maybe there were better moves but
this looks really beautiful you've
locked down this flank now the queen
side is blacks and alarisa needs to
fight back you have to speed up it's
frozen yeah yeah well he's made his move
oh is that a blunder and you can just
see the evaluation bar just zoom all the
way down in Black's favor I mean I think
Bishop F5 is just a move which very
logical move here you cannot take it
with oh he doesn't find it can't take it
with the Knight now because the night
the other night would be hanging on C3
uh this would lose a piece after The
Rook takes here but uh if you take with
another piece for example the bishop
only now Bishop F5 would have won the
game on the spot crashing in on C2 uh
Magnus doesn't see it but still in the
driver's seat the H5 can't be a bad move
maybe trying to loosen up the white king
side over here and it's getting near
that that stage already now and we did
see uh those uh images from the bullet
Chess Championship between these two
they are quite good at bullet chess both
of them as well but who would be the
favorite if we're down to the minute
taking yeah I mean they were punching
each other they were hitting each other
striking knocking lumps out of each
other uh trading blows there forgetting
the material next turn this white knight
uh will disappear on C3
what else is he thinking about he's got
to take the piece yeah there we go he
does eventually go for it but okay still
a two and a bit uh minute Advantage for
farugia at least now the pawn structure
is in Balance well they're not tempting
that's the whole point they're they're
both unattractive in their own way so
okay see he does capture with a rook and
there we see Magnus step back with a
bishop and now the Knight on C3 is
pinned
but you know what a White's position
he's he's uh if he can get out of this
pin his pieces his Bishop in the middle
of the board they're starting to look
quite nicer white I mean it's improving
for alireza definitely he's also always
got a threat of taking the Black Knight
opening up magnus's King
massive improvement from alares just
over the last few moves Magnus maybe not
finding the killer blow it's hard to in
Armageddon when you're watching the
clock and okay he's curled up into a
ball he's defended everything Magnus has
traded off his beautiful Bishop in order
to win a Pawn on A2 with his Rook coming
down the board to check the king and
this this would be a very tragic Bishop
coming in adding to the Firepower there
so that that move you can't play now but
it's always there as a threat Magnus
taking another Pawn
um wow this is this is really now
getting to the critical critical point
oh
anoreza pushes his pawns forward this is
just him taking risks in a must-win
situation uh that's not the move he
wanted to play if he was happy with the
draw there maybe he could have slapped
off the Black Knight Queens would have
come off in a draw but okay he's got to
win here and Magnus is off the board
great move there brilliant move love it
look at how he's going to trade queens
now there we go Queens have been
eliminated it costs black oppon but he
had two extra pawns anyway Magnus is
playing for the draw here that's all he
needs to look at the clock he's only 30
seconds down he's a massive favorite to
hold this he's pulling down he's got it
okay this this the move that Ivanka
recommended looks like a good try you've
got to try to get your pieces into the
game Magnus moves quickly Magnus
threatening to win a piece now with that
Bishop he just moved coming down to add
pressure to White's light Square Bishop
he can come all the way down that light
Square Bishop is pinned so Ali razor is
threatened with quite a nasty move there
if you step back with the King you're
just gonna get checked and that's why
Ali Reza's had to sound the retreat but
unfortunately now it's the night that's
going to spring forward to the F4 Square
it's quite handy isn't it as well so
alaris's body language is not positive
right now he knows that he's on the
brink of elimination and he's come close
he's taken it to Armageddon but how is
he ever going to win this position of
porn down facing this pin on the second
rank the deadly pin there his Bishop's
now getting kicked around the board and
uh black has various ways to guide this
game for safety let alone a mistake
after uh investing a lot of time will
Magnus do the same wow he's jumped in
with his Knight oh he's trying to go for
the draw he's not playing for the win
here Magnus Carlson he's just giving up
his night after the white Rook takes
it's been lured away and Simon's idea
black Bishop jumping to F1 winning that
pinned there we go winning that pinned
white bishop and notice how the
remaining Bishops on the board will be
of opposite color so for this one almost
dead drawn now yeah I mean uh unless
your Bishop gets in some trouble but I
don't think it does I mean yeah this
this uh
obviously should be a draw now uh
White's piece is slightly better though
so white can try to get in but opposite
color Bishops I mean uh these are uh
they can never challenge each other so
they can keep passing each other in the
wind there because they're on different
colored squares so they always just
drift by meaning that they can't hit the
same Target so a draw becomes very
likely and uh whilst a draw might be
likely it's not the result that alireza
wants and uh better in mind that if
there's any side that is pushing for the
win it's going to be black with that
extra pawn and the bishop attacking the
H3 Pawn there and Magnus just uh ask a
question to the C5 Bishop there is a
check the king can hide when he's going
in there's only one weak spot in Black's
camp and that is the Pawn on the dance
Square on G7 next to black king you lose
on time no increment you lose the game
and uh that's quite an aggressive move
he's checking the king and he's he's
securing the draw right and now the Rick
is going to come down
yeah with Harry and with the brook H4
that'd be a very appropriate way to
finish the match I feel checkmate with
Harry and uh there it goes into the
board and he's now taking some pawns and
is there any way the black king can get
in danger here
um I mean I don't see it but the black
king is a little bit short of squares
but
you need to get you need to get the
white king the only chance now I think
is for the white king to try to encroach
on the black King's position and to get
a checkmating net around it or to win on
time real tense finish to this because
in a moment look at him
I think he's like what what am I doing
I'm spending far too long but now it's a
private game white has the chance to
actually push the F Pawn to F5 and
create like some kind of attack on the
black king you know Magnus here he's
banking on the Black Brook sliding
behind the white king with a check and
uh there's some Targets on the e-file
pin oh always drop what's happened here
though okay but the H poor now surely
can come forwards yeah and that H Pawn
is two is a couple of squares of
queening but they are playing so calm
for under a minute now uh they and but
this could be a killer there's a big
fret H2 H1 queen and I don't think
there's any Checkmate Nets there the
only the only chance is to go F5 as you
say uvanka Bishop takes Pawn maybe you
could try that here push the pawn to F5
H2 Bishop takes F6 threatening Checkmate
could be could be worth it is the only
chance that white has otherwise the age
Pawn is just gonna Queen and he's
setting it up and Magnus has to be
careful and Magnus is
now the black king has some light
squares to escape to Magnus finally kind
of makes a head movement and he knows
he's winning his Pawn is soon going to
promote first he gives a check
okay still a bit nervy here but 22
seconds for farooja it surely isn't
enough to even complete this game
I mean yeah but that was a nervy check
there they are they are so nervous in
this match you can see it coming forward
giving up his Rook wow he's giving up
his Rook to try and promote the black F
Pawn but uh white truck would then have
to give itself up and that would have
been a draw Magnus is going to win on
the clock here 12 seconds 10 seconds now
for alireza this one is overlooked the
Pawn's about to promote yeah he's going
for checkmate but this is forlorn yeah
black queen on the board now is going to
win this game Magnus he's got it he's
got it in the end wow what a fight
though that was amazing the over Magnus
cross he takes it this is the winner of
the Julius bear generation cup after an
exciting final match here against
alireza furuja who took it too